so this is a screenshot of desmos it's
an online graphing calculator and what
we're going to do is use it to
understand how we can go about scaling
functions and I encourage you to go to
desmos and try it on your own either
during this video or after so let's
start with a nice interesting function
let's say f of X is equal to the
absolute value of x so that's pretty
straightforward now let's try to create
a scaled version of f of X so we could
say G of X is equal to well I'll start
with just absolute value of x so it's
the same as f of X so it just trace to G
of X right on top of F but now let's
multiply it by some constant let's
multiply it by 2 so notice the
difference between G of X and f of X and
you can see that G of X is just 2 times
f of X in fact we can write it this way
we can write G of X is equal to 2 times
f of X we get to the exact same place
but you can see that as as our x
increases G of X increases twice as fast
at least for positive X's on the
right-hand side and actually as X
decreases G of X also increases twice as
fast so it's not just a coincidence that
we have a 2 here and it increased twice
as fast well let's put a 3 here well now
it looks like it's increasing 3 times as
fast and it does that in both directions
now what if we were to put a zero point
five year zero point five well now it
looks like it's increasing half as fast
and that makes sense because we are just
multiplying we are scaling how much our
f of X is so before when x equals one we
got to one but now when x equals 1 we
can only get to one half before when x
equals five we got to 5 now when we go
to x equals five we only get to two
point five so we're increasing half as
fast or we have half the slope now an
interesting question to think about is
what would happen if instead of it just
being an absolute value of x let's say
we were to have a non zero y-intercept
so let's say
I don't know plus 6 so notice then when
we change this constant out front it not
only just changes the slope but it
changes the y-intercept because we're
multiplying this entire expression by
0.5 so if you multiply it by 1 we're
back to where we got before and now if
we multiply it by 2 this should increase
the y-intercept because remember we're
multiplying both of these terms by 2 and
we see that it not only doubles the
slope but it also increases the
y-intercept if we go to 0.5
not only did it decrease the slope by a
factor of 1/2 or or I guess you could
say multiply the slope by 1/2 but it
also made our y-intercept be half of
what it was before and we can see this
more generally if we just put a general
constant here and we can add a slider
and actually let me make the constant go
from 0 to 10 with a step of 0.05 that's
just how much does it increase every
time you change the slider and notice
when we increase our constant not only
we're getting narrower because the slope
the magnitude of the slope is being
scaled but our y-intercept increases and
then as K decreases our y-intercept is
being scaled down and our slope is being
scaled down now that's one way that we
could go about scaling but what if
instead of multiplying our entire
function by some constant we instead
just replace the X with a constant times
X so instead of K times f of X what if
we did f of K times X another way to
think about is G of X is now equal to
the absolute value of K X plus 6
what do you think is going to happen
pause this we didn't think about it well
now when we increase K notice it has no
impact on our y-intercept because it's
not scaling the y-intercept but it does
have an impact on slope when K goes from
1 to 2 once again we are now increasing
twice as fast and then when K goes from
one
to one half we're now increasing half as
fast now this is with an absolute value
function what if we did it with a
different type of function let's say we
did it with a quadratic so 2 minus X the
squared and let me scroll down a little
bit and so you can see when K equals 1
these are the same and now if we
increase our K let's say we increase our
K - 2 notice our parabola is our in this
case decreasing as we get further and
further from zero at a faster and faster
rate that's because what you would have
seen at x equals 2 you're now seeing at
x equals 1 because you are multiplying 2
times that and so and if we in and then
if we go between 0 and 1
notice on either side of 0 our parabola
is decreasing at a lower rate it's a
changing rate but it's a lower changing
rate I guess you could put it that way
and we could also try just to see what
happens with our parabola here if
instead of doing K X we once again put
the K out front what is that going to do
and notice that is changing not only how
fast the curve changes at different
points but it's now also changing the
y-intercept because we are now scaling
that y-intercept so I'll leave you there
this is just the beginning of thinking
about scaling I really want you to build
an intuitive sense of what is going on
here really think about mathematically
why it makes sense and go onto desmos
and play around it with yourself and and
also try other types of functions and
see what happens